now to the latest legal fight over the
nfl in racial equity commissioner roger
goodell is telling owners that the
league does not have enough head coaches
of color that follows a lawsuit by fired
miami dolphins coach brian flores
accusing the nfl of racial
discrimination in hiring the league had
said those allegations are without merit
i think we're at a fork in the road
right now you know we're either going to
keep it the way it is
or we're going to go in another
direction and actually make some real
change where we're actually changing the
hearts and minds of those who make
decisions in a memo to nfl teams
commissioner roger goodell responded to
brian flores's lawsuit writing we have
made significant efforts to promote
diversity however we must acknowledge
that particularly with respect to head
coaches the results have been
unacceptable goodell says the league
will reevaluate its diversity and
inclusion policies related to race and
gender one of those policies is the
rooney rule which requires teams to
interview minority candidates for
management and coaching positions flores
and his legal team called goodell's
letter quote on the surface a positive
first step but said it's more of a
public relations ploy than a real
commitment to change goddale also said
the league would investigate flores
allegations that dolphins owner steven
ross offered to pay him to lose games
allegations ross vehemently denies this
game you know changed my life
so to
attack the integrity of the game that's
that's what i felt was happening in that
instance and
i wouldn't stand for it
brian flores will get some clarity soon
as he is considered a top finalist for
the houston texas job last night the
dolphins hired mike mcdaniel to be their
head coach mcdaniel who is biracial will
become the fourth minority head coach
currently in the nfl goodell plans to
give a super bowl press conference on
wednesday where he is sure to be asked
about the lawsuit in the league's plans
for change it'll be interesting to see
what he has to say i don't know if i'd
call it a public relations ploy so
quickly right the fact that roger
goodell even raised the issue i think
and acknowledged and acknowledged
now it's time to walk the walk now it's
time to do that i don't know if i'd call
it a public relations point right now
it'll be interesting to see what he does
feels like a big deal for him to come
out and say look it's it's unacceptable
the number of minority head coaches we
have in this league no doubt we'll see
if change comes that's for sure yes it
is time a lot of people pulling for
brian flores though today